hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within hi
how are you I don't know if you should
be here I was under the impression here
we go my kitty okay
right alright okay I see how this is
gonna be I see how this games gonna be
so there's a little bit of madness to
this method are you watching me
what is that damn squeaking okay so is
that actually something when I'm
supposed to climb I guess that answers
that question if some glad this game is
so helpful to me oh I'm digging dog
something for me to pry open with my
strong okay I went in there rather
urgently that's a good sound oh he'll
never see me through this hidden mirror
glass haha I've got the upper hand now
how would I just go so there's got to be
over here
I knew there had to be a way yes please
I don't know what awaits me on this
other side there's some goodies like I
know that it's probably not gonna happen
but I what is that whoa
oh cool I don't know this is this
something that I'm gonna find out now or
is this a secret from the first part of
the game now that's a good question
because if it is I have no idea it's not
then I should be okay ooh
ten okay so it is I get it
I got it oh that's the number 215 so and
there's got to be a something that tells
me the order of the third oh it's right
in there I didn't notice that the door
was open sorry I'm a I'm a doof all five
right in front of my face okay so oh
they're color-coded okay so red was red
was ten yeah red was ten on the first
try Wow there's meat in here I forgot
about the meat okay let her scrap is
that supposed to help me in some way
because this particular scrap of this
letter seems to have scribbled out words
great alright anything else in here that
I need any other goodies no is that it
okay so I imagine that the letter scrap
has got to be a piece of a bigger puzzle
that I'm gonna get down the road I swear
I keep seeing things out of the corner
of my eye like just for some reason I
remember the end levels of the
originally evil within and how there was
just meat splayed about everywhere you
could hope for
why'd you come a-runnin in there I'm
here now apparently well I didn't mean
to do that but I'm going rad that's not
what I wanted to do I'm in trouble what
what was that little gallop there what
okay okay I'm gonna run now thanks for
not hurting me I did a thing I just
don't know what I did oh no it's right
there it's Chloe
dude it's glowing okay oh oh oh goodness
oh okay here we go
keycard huh so this goes to here no not
that you dingleberry get in there thank
you slide away now we can go forward now
we can progress oh that's that's that
that's less than helpful
it's awfully panic-inducing when i don't
have a weapon and it's great isn't it
not so cool one more okay I love the way
the colors shift in every place you go
oh this is a secret yeah I wonder if I
should focus in on there with my light
okay I don't think you'd let me forget
wait am I supposed to wait I thought
this was supposed to do a thing wasn't
that the point and why does a symbol
look so communist where's Jojo
where's what's its face the detective
where am I supposed to go oh oh oh oh I
get it okay I get it now I got it I got
it almost there
oh there little one more like like that
good excuse me
just aside to heel kick my way into you
for no reason I know that the other
detective how-to proclivity to fascist
sour the air fell heavy there were
hidden desks in the parents of secrets
of diffusion indoctrination big words
they brought me into their fold this
place is elaborate to say the least
despite the modernistic visit the
research they've been doing here seems
to date back to over a century a girl
hmm this place has history and from what
I can grasp this facility is only one
branch of many institutions powerful
families their reach seems grand and
therefore the possibilities for me seem
equally as rich yet clearly my own
unique methods at beacon have piqued
their interest and I am most grateful
for the opportunity most of what the
researchers have been working on however
seems archaic by today's standards they
told me budget is of no concern results
are the only thing that matter juggling
duties here at the hospital seems
manageable but Ruben leaves it
comparatively insignificant but even at
his young age his studies are remarkable
perhaps one day he will even assist me
with my work here Oh more than you know
that's the doctor who's behind
everything the doctor who was playing
very very special partisan that's him
we're expected to reach a solution hence
the founding of this facility I
understand that do you
and I appreciate the time you've given
me do you time has a limit and we're
approaching that point you've you've
outspent your usefulness we will need to
find someone more suitable no don't be
so hasty I've done tests with our visual
diagnosis
there is something I must speak to you
about please come with me
ah detector is in the next room right
okay
I see so he was a little desperate to
get results which is probably why all of
this went awry what is what is that oh
it's down here okay oh I thought I saw
like a mannequin or something here the
big stiletto lady
oh it's Rubick Rubick how you doing
there friend oh boy I bet you're having
a good time being dead in the future
alright so over here okay got it got it
so I'm just trying to make sure that I
cover absolutely everything hello
that's a cool mechanic I really like
that oh it's an old to accomplish what
we intend you will need to refocus we
need direct access and what do you
propose
it's a pet project the saucier Emeco
chemical process with it we should be
able to have a direct influence on the
individual potentially even access their
subconscious I have the data all right
let's see yeah I remember they showed me
that when I was brought here
at the beginning of the indoctrination
process we thank you for appearing these
magical doors everywhere very useful
okay bye
I hear the thing in the other image boom
hello I want to make sure I'm not
missing out on anything this is stem
thing oh cool so that is the stem thing
those are the beds where people lie and
they get hooked up to the big brain and
they go into the strange world what am I
not supposed to do anything about those
am I just supposed to look at them for
my own plate
sure oh hey is there any others yep okay
those are the bathtubs that you're
supposed to lay in but uh so okay
looking for stem I'm sure you and your
superiors will find this most
satisfactory Oh will you mentioned the
design was from a pupil of yours in that
case where do you fit in he is an
unstable individual mmm perhaps it is
better that I continue to be the one to
contact in this situation I'd like you
to bring this man in you should all be
able to have a productive conversation
what did you say his name was
toriana
also known as ruvik the guy in charge of
this hell that I'm in right now so that
that was hinted at in the first game
oh oh oh where do I go
oh oh oh crap oh crap okay I don't know
oh come on with that baloney I am the
worst hider in the history of anything
ever and I don't even know if I needed
to hide from anything I am such an idiot
wandering around the circle's and then
I've run out of breath and stop in the
middle of the hallway oh it's all my own
fault I'm such an idiot
that's not the controls that was totally
on me I swear in panicked well I could
do like a big goober
I'm not gonna risk jumping through those
doors that are slamming shut over there
okay so what's with these giant doors
anyway oh hello
alrighty then where am I now
okay me neither
Jojo yay oh no come back
that's where Leslie was before uh-huh
and now those two where are they headed
would those two how dare they be them
who they are I'm gonna show them a thing
or two just over here that's exactly
what I was hoping for so now I can go
get my ID reinstated and be able to
travel around here even though I'm
technically only inside my own mind and
all of this doesn't make a whole ton of
sense but with that being said I'm gonna
accept it fully because as long as I do
not have a gun I am just fine trust me
on that I am 100% a ok with this this is
so cool
it's so awesome it's slow and methodical
I'm taking my time with things
immediately I could be going a little
faster but I want to make sure that I
get everything and I think that's why I
noticed that the control scheme has
slightly changed because I think it
definitely is like
we'll take you a while yeah no joke yes
right
oh okay I see how this was seriously and
bring him back that's all that matters
apparently that's all that matters
because I'm fully into the Mobius which
is cool I guess zhan my biometrics my
good to go free access anywhere I do I
don't know how to do all those things
okay I'm gonna slam my face into there
as hard as possible and hope for the
best that's what I do and everything I
do everything okay ow my brain
thank you good picture cool thanks
what does that mean also this place
looks creepy are they really dead I sure
hope so
oh boy they're not dead are they which
one's gonna pop out at me okay so where
am I going now yeah that's what I was
saying like it seemed different because
I believe that the controls are
different like it's a tighter
perspective I don't know
okay okay
goddamn that's not okay man that's not
okay don't do that you're all going to
vent that seems like a good idea oh crap
oh crap is it coming down that way I
don't want to go down there now ah you
son of a [ __ ] you want to dance huh
I got heel kicks for days you okay
yeah sure let's go with that let me
shine a light right at it okay that's
not cool that's not cool that it's not
okay I'm 100% not okay with that holy
crap this is awesome I love it
this is exactly what I was hoping for
this is awesome okay I did not get to
tail kick the solution to hell there's a
lot of these things are gonna kill me
one hit if they get to me okay so I need
to get over there I need to get those
bottles for distraction purposes okay
let's not do anything too hasty how do I
get around you oh god don't stop eating
all right can I jump over this no I
can't
great why did I come over here oh so
gross is that a brain or those lungs
does it even matter it's gross okay I
think I can slip by this one I don't
think I can slip by the other one you
don't oh god you're weird oh you are -
oh boy oh that's right I forgot I can
lure enemies thanks for the reminder
that's actually a helpful hint okay
[Music]
you're so weird
slip right by me this it is cool because
the tighter perspective of the camera if
that is what it is I maybe it's wider I
don't even know
ooh it's a guessing game yeah I'm good
at these now watch me fail over and over
again cool I got another piece Oh No
number three where did I miss one
already already I've missed him I'm such
a dingleberry but I'm a dingleberry
who's having fun oh man
well everyone knows I'm not bro Gerard
the completion er froze your bro Gerard
the finished that's all of us so I just
got to do a luring call but when I do a
luring call I know it's not gonna it's
not gonna go well
bachchi oh crap oh crap you didn't see
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing oh you're oh you're all
different that is fun okay excuse me
that worked surprisingly well I'll be on
my way now
oh it's so cool and so creepy okay here
we go
big old switch yeah good slow-moving
gate probably loud we're definitely
loved ok bye ok bye ok bye ok bye ok bye
oh boy another one loud I hope so oh boy
it is you stay down
Oh No oh I missed my chance
geez oh no no no no no no you guys are
not fun you oh you guys are the anti fun
Oh what are you doing is this just
something what you do all day
let's go in a freaking circle over and
over plug in idiot I mean I hate say but
I calls it like i sees him yeah you
don't look too smart new and none of
that slips lipid he slipped slipped
movie like what is the point what is the
point of your existence I mean again I
don't want to be mean but hey I really I
just calls them like I see them you're
you're weird really really weird okay
don't tell me enough oh why did I come
in here why did I lock myself in here
why did I do these things okay all right
so I got a get okay so I got to get in
that gap over there
that's such baloney that's such baloney
in this game knows it I'm not gonna make
it I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna
make it I'm not gonna make it I'm not
gonna make it I'm not gonna make it oh
this is why I need to do you pull this
oh excuse me why the explode I've got
some goofy on me oh I didn't know they
exploded but why not it just adds to the
fun how am I supposed to do this get up
you almost lizard my face off so weird
so creepy oh don't blow up don't blow me
up
don't don't blow nothing oh you walk
weird - why are you crab walking
why must you crab walk okay come on
hurry please now would be a great time
now would be a good time Oh God
I could have made that but I better safe
than sorry
better safe than sorry okay here we go
all right we made it okay I can't do
that yet that's right I came here to get
this biometric [ __ ] out of the way
okay get it done get it done right get
it done good
what oh it's a neural scan that's right
that's not yeah why do I need a brain
scan sure does yeah it doesn't make
sense because this is all a dream world
it's all made of pyruvic none of its
real
none of it is applicable hopefully this
gets me back yes does array for
shortcuts stay alive they burn happy
this is this is amazing by the way
because I'm really holding on to hope
that I'm never gonna get a weapon
throughout this entire deal see which
feet
all right good we did a little
switcheroo I'm glad that happened
I'm glad okay this is bad what's going
on nothing
okay for the first time my character was
more scared than I am
oh okay here we go right back to the
same point that's awesome oh this game
so cool oh it's so cool I love it
it's amazing this is awesome this is
everything I wanted alright so that's
all for the second part that I got I
really hope you're enjoying this one I
am too I'm gonna move right on to the
third episode thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]